MRI is a medical imaging device commonly
used to examine the soft tissues of the
human body
let's meet the machine the key
components are the magnet radio waves
gradient and a computer
our bodies are made up of 60% water and
water is magnetic each of the billions
of water molecules inside us consists of
an oxygen atom bonded to two hydrogen
atoms we know it has h2o small parts of
the hydrogen atoms act as tiny magnets
and a very sensitive to magnetic fields
MRI stands for magnetic resonance
imaging and an MRI scanner is one of the
main diagnostic tools that doctors use
to examine inside our bodies the first
step in taking an MRI scan is to use a
big magnet to produce a unified magnetic
field around the patient the gradient
adjusts the magnetic field into smaller
sections of different magnetic strengths
to isolate specific body parts for
example the brain normally the water
molecules inside us are arranged
randomly but when we lie inside the
magnetic field most of our water
molecules move at the same rhythm or
frequency as the magnetic field the ones
that don't move along the magnetic field
are called low energy water molecules to
create an image of a body part
for example the brain the machine
focuses on the low energy water
molecules radio waves move at the same
rhythm or frequency as the magnetic
fields in an MRI machine by sending
radio waves that match or resonate with
the magnetic field the low energy water
molecules absorb the energy they need to
move alongside the magnetic field
when the machine stops emitting radio
waves the water molecules that had just
moved along the magnetic field release
the energy they had absorbed and go back
to their position this movement is
detected by the MRI machine and the
signal is sent to a powerful computer
which uses imaging software to translate
the information into an image of the
body by taking images of the body in
each section of the magnetic field the
machine produces a final three
dimensional image of the organ which
doctors can analyze to make a diagnosis